They say one little leak can sink a massive
ship - massive ship - can completely sink
because of one little leak.
By the way, your business, your enterprise,
you as an entrepreneur, you can absolutely
sink your ship if you don't plug the little
leaks you have in your business.
And today, I'm going to talk to you about
three different companies, from three different
industries, if I'm running them, how I'm going
to find those leaks and how I would plug them.
I wish we had hours and hours together to
go through your business, but whatever I'm
talking about here today, I'm going to give
you feedback on what you need to do at the
end with your business.
So, the first thing I do is whenever I'm running
any business, and we have an area that's not
going well.
Like today we just had a conference call.
It was a pretty strong conference call I had
with everybody, and we went through areas
that we need to be improving in.
First thing I do is I write out all the steps.
And I do this with every aspect of my life
and my business.
For instance, if it's health, I write out
every single thing I do with my diet and every
single routine I have with working out, and
every single routine I have with sleep, everything.
So step #1 is take out your business and write
all the steps.
It could be 20 steps.
It could be 10 steps.
Customer comes in, what they do next and what
they do . . . until they buy from you.
All the steps.
Once you write all the steps, prioritize the
five most important steps.
So go this is the most important step, then
this, then this, then this.
Then rank how well you do in each step.
Then bring a group of two, three, four, five
people that work with you that are also leaders,
who can say, I think we can do this to improve.
I think we can do this to improve this.
We're not doing this that well.
Then put an action plan together and attack
the action plan.
So whatever I just told you right now, watch
how I do this with these different businesses.
I've got a sales office, any sales office,
real estate, insurance, it doesn't matter
what it is, sales office.
We've got a restaurant here, and then we have
a construction business here.
Let's start here with sales office.
I'm running a sales office.
Real estate, pharmaceuticals sales, whatever
it is.
I want to find out where my leaks in my business
are.
So I either have inbound calls or customers
coming in, or I have outbound calls, reaching
out.
I'm reaching out or I'm getting the call.
I'm getting an email of interest.
I'm getting a message.
I'm getting a visit to my business, whatever
it is.
Or I'm outbound.
So if I'm inbound call, somebody calls me,
yes, I would like to talk to a real estate
agent about buying a house, hypothetically.
What is my script?
I test the script.
What is the questions asked?
What questions are we asking, the sales rep
is asking the customer that's called in.
Three, what are my FAQs?
Do I have an FAQ sheet.
For instance, If you're running real estate,
there are 20 questions that everybody's going
to ask.
Everybody that buys a house asks the same
exact questions.
Everybody that's selling and buying asks the
same exact questions.
So I need an FAQ sheet.
Do I have an FAQ sheet?
Next thing is called call to action.
So let's just say a person calls, I have a
script.
And I ask questions, they ask me questions,
I already know the FAQs.
Then it's call to action.
Meaning, "when do you want to buy the house?
How soon do you want to buy the house?
Are you already prequalified?
Do you already have a property?
Do you already know what area?"
I'm asking, call to action, what do we do
next.
Then we're going to go.
Schedule a time to go do whatever we're doing.
And then we're going to close.
And when I close, then it's follow up, once
I got the close.
Then I follow up as we got closed.
Then there's onboarding, paperwork, all this
stuff, filling out all these things I've got
to do.
Then it's referral, then it's nurturing that
relationship.
If it's outbound, and I'm reaching out to
the customer.
Let's just say I am a social media marketing
company and I'm running an agency and I'm
outbound.
I'm trying to reach out to people.
First I have to identify who my ideal client
is.
Do I even know who my ideal client is to call?
Then it's volume of contacts, meaning if I'm
selling a membership to a magazine, it's volume.
If I'm selling a subscription to a certain
membership or whatever, it's volume.
If I'm selling a gym membership, it's volume.
I'm calling everybody.
But if I'm selling exotic cars, Lamborghinis,
Ferraris, I'm not contacting 200 people in
a day.
I'm nurturing, meaning I'm going to country
club events.
I'm going to certain speaking events.
I'm going to certain places that people of
money are going to be around.
So volume is quantity vs. quality, depending
on the product that you sell.
You need to be clear about that.
Then, am I good at finding customers?
Some companies have finding problems.
They don't know how to find the right customers.
Then what's my script, when I'm outbound.
Closing, do I close well?
Do I have a finding or closing problem?
Follow up, onboarding, nurture, all the same.
So now, once I know what my inbound and outbound
is, and I write this out.
Let's just say this is you.
I'm going to circle the most important ones
on inbound.
For instance, FAQs.
That's important for everybody to know the
FAQs.
Great, that's important.
Questions asked is important.
Close is important.
And man, follow up has to be up there.
Then I'm going to score every one of them
how well we do.
Our script sucks, man.
We're at two.
We don't even have a script, honestly.
Two, questions asked, we don't even know what
questions to ask.
Three, FAQs - we do have somewhat of an FAQ,
six.
I'm scoring all of them.
Then whatever those four were that were important
to me, and whatever the ones that are the
lowest ranking, I'm figuring out how to improve
those.
And I improve them.
It's that simple.
I'm doing the same thing here [outbound].
And I'm improving it.
Then I get a couple ideas, then we improve.
Again.
Let me do another example.
Here's a restaurant.
I'm running a restaurant.
I have a lot of friends that come to me for
advice about restaurants and they run restaurants
from doing a half a million a year to restaurants
doing $15 million per year.
And they're always asking, "How would you
improve this.
How would you improve that?"
And for me, I've been to thousands of restaurants
around the world, and I love good food.
And I'm so meticulous, that I pay attention
to every single thing about restaurants, because
if I ever ran one, I would want it to be ran
in a certain way.
This is what I'd be paying attention to if
I'm you.
Your location of your restaurant.
You say, "I'm not doing that well."
Is it even a good location?
I went to a restaurant the other day, yesterday
in Houston, Paul, and we're looking at the
sushi spot.
The sushi spot was all the way in the back.
I couldn't even find this place.
Food was great.
Everything was good.
Horrible location.
If this is the main street, these were the
businesses up front, the sushi spot was here.
There is no street there.
That's a horrible, horrible location for it,
right?
So location.
Where can I be found online, Yelp, on apps,
am I everywhere?
Parking, is parking available.
Next, entrance, presentation.
I'm scoring every one of these, from 0 - 10.
I am truly scoring every one of those zero
to 10.
Next, my process, hostess.
What's the script when somebody comes?
Who do I hire?
What is the attire?
What is she wearing?
What is he wearing?
What's their look?
What's their attitude?
Do I want somebody attractive?
What age do I want?
How helpful do I want them to be?
How do I attract how helpful they are?
I'm scoring this with all my hostesses.
If I've got five hostesses, I'm scoring every
one of them and I'm firing the bottom two,
okay?
If they're not at all like this, I'm firing
them.
So meaning I'm hiring somebody to shop them.
Let me explain what I mean by shopping them.
When I worked at Bally and I was selling memberships
at Bally, I used to shop all the other Bally.
Everybody would say, "This Bally in Chicago
is the best one!
This Bally in New York is the best one!"
I'm working at Bally.
I would call that Bally.
Until the best guy at that Bally picked up.
And I would act like I'm a customer, wanting
to buy a membership.
And see how he handled it.
I'm like, "wow, no wonder this guy's number
two in the company.
No wonder this guy's number three in the company.
No wonder this guy's number one in the company.
He is a beast in closing on an appointment.
I didn't even know what to say.
He closed me, and I work at Bally."
I'm shopping all my hostesses.
I'm bringing 10 people, and I'm having all
them shop them.
Different personalities, single mother, single
female, a husband and wife, kids, I want a
whole experience, how she handles kids being
rattled and loud, I want to shop my hostesses.
Next, ambiance.
What's the music?
Is it too loud?
What kind of music am I playing?
Is it hip hop music?
Is it a lounge with jazz?
Is it more salsa?
Is it more like current music that we have?
Is it just, you know, the white noise music?
What am I playing?
What station am I playing here?
How loud is it?
How's the lighting?
How's the dress attire and the ambiance, right?
Decorations, smell.
Is there scent for it?
Is there a smell?
If I go into a place that smells bad, I walk
out immediately, right?
Service.
Waiter, how long it waits to come.
For instance, I'm here, I come in.
I'm timing this if I'm running a restaurant.
You got to do this with your business.
I walk into a restaurant.
Okay.
A restaurant that's empty, and it took me
six minutes to get seated, you're annoyed.
I want to know from the moment I walk in to
how soon I get seated.
If you're an A-rated restaurant, I'm coming
for the service and the food.
I have expectations of sit down, if I don't
have a reservation.
I'm okay with that.
But if I come in, from the moment you sit
me down, how long does it take for the waiter
to come and say hello?
The other day I was at CPK that we went to
that one time.
You came, Mario came, the day after we launched
the 2017 rewind, if you remember that, in
Plano.
You came by.
We went to that same CPK with me, Tico and
Dylan.
Five year old and a three year old.
When you come with a kid, I expect you to
pay attention to the fact that this father
comes with two boys, a father does know.
. . you know, I'm sitting there by myself.
It took seven minutes for the girl to come
say hello to me.
So finally I screamed out, "Who's working
on this side?
Who's working on this side?"
They're all like, "Oh, sir, we're so sorry."
Who's my waiter?
Seven minutes I've been sitting here.
I've got two kids.
You guys don't pay attention.
The place was 20 percent full.
So finally the person comes.
Very, very good waiter.
He comes and says, "I'm so sorry sir.
She's busy."
She wasn't busy.
She had one other table.
But he's willing to do that.
Perfect.
I like the team work there.
The other girl needs to be fired.
He takes an order.
He puts it in.
The girl comes an apologizes.
Whatever happens, we leave.
I would have fired her like this [snap].
This is not her job to do.
That's stuff I'm paying attention to.
Right?
Speed.
Quality of food.
Without good food, you're a done deal, right?
Then you have manager greetings.
How many times you go to a restaurant.
I love it when this happens.
I'm sitting.
The waiter keeps coming, doing their thing.
But a manager comes.
How's the service here today?
Everything is good.
Enjoying yourself?
Is there anything I can help you with?
Not at all.
Thank you so much.
That little subtle movement increases my impression
of the restaurant by at least 10%.
So if you're not doing that, I'd be doing
that, right?
Speed.
Upselling.
Do you upsell?
Would you like to try this?
Oh, let me tell you my favorite items on the
menu is this.
If you're going to have this, it's good to
do this.
By the way, you sure you don't want to have
a red wine with this?
You know, it goes good with this.
Let me tell you what red wine I recommend.
The other day I went to Capital Grill, a restaurant
here.
And my wife and I went back to back.
It's not every day you go to a restaurant
twice, especially that kind of restaurant.
But we went back to back, Friday and Saturday
night.
Look how scripted this Capital Grill place
was.
We go in, and the guy says, Oh my gosh, let
me just tell you about this one red wine that
we have.
I think we only have two or three bottles
left.
Let me check.
And this is the best bottle of wine you want
to have.
It's $99.
. . We only have a couple of bottles left.
So what does my wife say?
I want to try it.
Great.
They bring the bottle of wine out.
The next day I go with Tom Ellsworth and his
wife.
The next day, not the same waiter, but another
waiter comes.
It's the same exact bottle of wine.
And he says, Oh, we have this bottle of wine.
I think we only have two or three bottles.
I have to check.
But if I do have it, it's only $99 a bottle.
And I didn't say anything.
I looked at my wife and I said, "that's a
script."
But you know what?
It's effective.
Because how often do a couple go to the same
Capital Grill restaurant back to back?
They don't.
It worked on day one.
It didn't work on day two.
But there was a script on how to upsell.
That upsell got them $99 upsell on the ticket,
at 20%, that's $20 more tip to the waiter.
Good for him.
That's upsell.
What's this over here?
Specials.
Can they say the specials?
I love when they say the specials and they
say it so eloquently.
You know what I'm talking about, when they
say, "Today's specials are with the.
. . " What they're saying on it, we don't
know what they're saying, but the way they
say it, and the temperature, and this is from
Bulgaria, and it's like, "Oh my gosh, I want
all of it!"
right?
There's a script to it.
There's a way you present that.
Dessert, handling complaints, technology.
This, if I'm running a restaurant, I'm writing
all of these things down.
I'm bringing it down to five importants.
I'm scoring my lowest area.
I'm bringing my team together of experts,
that know what we're doing.
And I say, "How can we improve this?"
Then call to action.
Then attacking all the calls to action.
Construction, same thing, inbound, outbound.
What's our script?
Do we know the client?
Who is our client?
Are they a homeowner?
Do we want $300,000 homes?
Do we want million dollar homes?
Who's our ideal client?
Are we going after construction of bigger
condominiums?
Who are we looking for?
Right?
Then prices over the phone.
For instance, if I'm running construction,
I'm not giving prices over the phone.
The first thing I want to do is I want to
come to your house.
I want to send somebody to come to your house
to get an estimate.
When I come to your house and I see what it
is, I'm paying attention to signs.
If I see artwork's not on the wall, if I see
a rinky-dink car parked outside, like a Toyota
Corolla and you want to do a $50,000 job and
that's our minimum, and I'm seeing the way
the house is not really decorated, maybe I'm
paying attention to clues.
And then after I find out when I visit the
property, I get a commitment.
What kind of range are you trying to get for
this kitchen upgrade?
Well, our budget is around $20,000."
They want $60,000 for $20,000.
Have you gotten already a commitment from
someone else?
Yes, we got an $18,000 commitment.
Can they do everything you asked for?
Yes.
Interesting.
Okay, so then I have to decide.
Do I want to make a bid to this?
And can I pry a little bit more to know who
it is?
How much work do they want to do?
Do they want better quality?
What quality wood?
All that stuff I'm asking for, right?
Quote, three options.
My sales people never leave with three options.
Follow up, close, finishing at time, delivering,
then client testimonials and referrals.
Same thing if I'm running a construction.
I'm scoring these.
And I'm finding out what I'm not good at.
Then what I'm not good at, as I address it,
I bring a team of three to five again and
I say, "What do we need to do to improve this?"
I fire the weakest link that I have on the
team that's not doing their part, right?
And then we put a plan of action together
and we attack it to improve the company.
I've done this.
I think I've done this since 2003, 2004.
Every time I find leaks in '03, it was my
credit score.
My credit score was terrible.
I put a system together and improved my credit
score to 822.
Savings, investments, health, relationship,
business, improvement, leadership, CEO, startup,
entrepreneurship, everything is a system for
you to put together.
Once you do that, and you find the leaks,
and you attack it, then you see three percent
growth here.
Eight percent growth here.
Nine percent growth here.
Thirteen percent growth here.
And you don't even see the compounding growth
of it over a five, ten year period.
Then all of a sudden, years later people are
saying, oh, he got lucky!
Oh, she got lucky with her business.
No, no, no, no, no.
While you, as the business owner went out
of business because you don't pay attention
to details, this entrepreneur decided to actually
act like an entrepreneur, pay attention to
the details, improve the business, and now
they have an established business that you
claim they got lucky.
If you do the same thing, you will have the
same results.
But you don't pay attention to the leaks,
that's why your ship sinks.
I'm not saying you, I'm saying the person
that didn't make it.
So you watching this, my challenge to you
is to take out a sheet of paper.
Write out the systems in your business.
Identify exactly what the leaks are.
Get the opinions of a couple of other people
Rank them.
Find out what they're suggesting to you.
Put a plan of action together.
Fire the bottom, weakest link.
Go attack the plan and see what happens to
your business.
That's my message of the week to you.
If you've got any questions and comments,
thoughts about this, comment on the bottom.
Take care everybody.
Bye bye.
Hey, thanks for watching this video.
Let me make a case for you why I believe you
need to subscribe to Valuetainment and also
join the notification squad.
Look, there's two ways you can learn about
business.
One of the ways is go to college.
Learn a bunch of theories by professors who
have probably never ran a business before
or you can watch Valuetainment, ran by entrepreneurs
who have built and sold businesses and you
can learn from our mistakes and what we do
right.
And by the way, I'm willing to bet anybody
who goes and takes this boring route vs. watches
Valuetainment, I'm putting my money on this
person who watches Valuetainment is going
to beat the person who goes to college.
You don't believe me?
Test me on this.
This is why I'm so certain you need to subscribe
to Valuetainment and learn the content so
you can also be a successful entrepreneur.